merci
c'est dur c'est
très dur ça pèse sur les garçons
et les filles ça pèse sur les membres du personnel
ça les impacte
je pense que nous n'avions pas bu l'eau
depuis environ
12 ans comme littéralement nous avons toujours
acheté notre eau
donc vous prenez toujours une chance  quand vous vous
baignez dedans
et que vous devez encore consommer beaucoup
d'
eau en bouteille et faire bouillir votre nourriture
parce que vous ne savez pas ce que l'eau est
vraiment contaminée
[Musique]
ce n'est pas comme ça que vous êtes censé construire
vous savez ce n'est pas normal  ce n'est pas
normal du tout parce que pendant
combien de temps nous devrons
acheter de l'eau  tu sais ce que
je dis
mais nous donnons une cruche réutilisable
nigga apportez-la ici et
remplissez-vous vous savez ce que je dis oh
[Musique]
toi